Is it true that you used to have a crush
on Christian Bale?
Oh my gosh, yes.
(laughing)
How do you know these things?
Oh my gosh, Christian Bale.
I don't know if you've seen the movie, "Newsies",
have you seen that?
Yeah.
It's a musical and he's singing
and he's wearing a newsboy cap
and it's not even like the sexiest version of himself,
but I was just like, "Oh, love."
And then of course he just got more and more sexier.
The more I think adult, wild roles he would play.
Okay. So I went like on a faux date with him
when I was like, I don't know, 10 years old.
I went to visit Steven Spielberg,
not name dropping, on this site of "Empire Of The Sun".
And Christian Bale was the star of that.
But he was also like, 10 too
and we went to like the Hard Rock Cafe in London
that was like super fun.
But I remember like, beating myself up
when he became like, a teenager
like, "Why didn't I see it that I could have married him
right then and there!"